from the documentation we want single
choice mode so that the list item only
shows one selected item at a time we can
declare this attribute on the ListView
in the fragment main file however we
don't want to specify choice mode in one
pane mode so to have these different
code paths we could copy the file in the
layout folder and put it in the layout
SW 600 DP folder a better solution is to
declare a style so we have one layout
file but different styles in the base
Styles file in the values folder we
declare a forecast list style we leave
it empty because we don't need to
specify choice mode we create a new
Styles file in the values SW 600 DP
folder in the two pane case the for
calculus style does include the choice
mode the two files have a different
number of styles if it's not declared in
a higher folder then it will just fall
back to the base style